- Hey guys, welcome to the Byers' house,
we're on the set of season three,
and I'm going to be giving you a tour.
(funky Music)
- Hey guys, it's Gaten here.
- Hi guys, I'm Millie Bobby Brown.
- Hi I'm Finn, maybe you
know that, maybe you don't.
I'm right now on the set, the studio lot
of "Stranger Things" in Atlanta, Georgia.
(funky music)
(fireworks exploding)
(whooshing)
(fireworks popping)
- Here is stage two,
where the cabin is with Eleven,
and just a bunch of cool little things.
(funky retro music)
- This is my set.
This is my house.
So, I've never actually used the bathroom,
I don't feel like Eleven's
ever actually peed,
which is interesting.
And then TV's gone, but
there's usually a TV here
that Eleven likes to watch her soaps on.
This is the wonderful cabinet
that fell to the ground
when Eleven used her
powers, she got real mad.
This is the kitchen.
This is where Eleven
and Hopper share their
very intense dinners and breakfasts,
and it's very cool because this
is a very easy table to move
and Eleven likes to shake it around.
And last but not least,
we have the best part of this house,
my bedroom.
Sorry, it's a little crowded in here.
(clearing throat)
Eleven's a little messy,
but this is actually a cute
little addition to my room.
It's some dice that says Mike on it,
because she's obsessed with Mike.
And this is her bed, and
there's some very exciting
smooching going on in
season three on this bed.
(laughing)
(claps)
And yeah, it's a very nice
room, I love it so much,
and I think Eleven loves
it too, so very cool.
So this is Hopper's
cabin, I hope you enjoyed!
(smooches)
- This is the parking where
Gaten always takes my spot.
It's always Gaten, and never anyone else.
It's always his fault.
Here's three and four,
stages three and four,
where the basement is,
and where everything started for us.
- It's pretty much the same
basement you know and love
from seasons one and two,
decorated for Christmas
for reasons I don't know,
but here you've got a
nice looking TV set here.
Over here is the beloved bathroom where
Mike and El almost have
their first kiss interrupted
by this guy right here.
That's probably my favorite
poster in the entire,
I wanna keep it once they
finish filming the show,
entirely, once it's over.
I want to keep that poster.
(funky music)
- This room is where Johnathan sleeps,
and this is my room right here.
(funky music)
The bed is very, very comfortable.
(bed creaking)
Hola.
This is where I do my drawings,
I listen to music.
This place is my favorite room.
And right here we have our bathroom.
This is where I throw up
slugs, this is where I pee.
Just clean myself, you know?
(upbeat music)
- I'm Millie Bobby Brown
again, good to see you.
Well, this is a set I've never worked in,
but I'm going to show you around anyway.
So, this is the part where the scientists
are all working out, you know.
This is where demodogs break through,
and then I save the day
once again, obviously.
But yeah, this is a really cool scene,
and really cool set,
and this is when I'm pretty sure,
one of the really cool scientists,
they have this really
cool shot right here,
and the air comes through,
and they're like
(mimicking dramatic music).
It's very cool, I like
that shot very much.
(funky music)
- This is the school rooms,
where right now it's not happening,
school is not happening right now
because we're on summer break,
and boy do I love the sound of that.
- [Crew] That's a rap on Priah.
- Okay, thank you.
- Thanks Priah,
you did amazing.
- So, we're going to school,
because after I'm done with
set I have to do school,
so that's where we're headed to right now.
Hi.
(clunking)
- [Woman] Priah, help me, do
you go to school alone here,
or do you have other
kids in class with you?
- I'm just alone, because,
my classmates, they're older than me.
- [Woman] What grade are
you in right now, Priah?
- I'm in sixth grade.
- [Woman] Can we come
in the class with you?
- No, I'm sorry you
cannot come into class!
Bye!
- Right here is the costume trailer.
(clanking)
- Welcome to costumes!
So quiet in here, it's like a library.
Tell us a little bit
about this room.
- Hey guys!
Well, this is where Caleb has
all of his principle fittings,
- [Caleb] Yes.
- and we've had really,
a ton of fun this season,
and our favorite outfit for this season
is our Karate Kid outfit.
- Yes.
(funky music)
- So, I have the honor of introducing you
to the dogs of "Stranger
Things", or the "Stranger Dogs".
This is Rocky, she loves belly rubs.
This is Sig, it's short for Sigourney,
and she is a rescue dog.
Aww, thank you!
This is Lady, she's three years old.
(woman laughing)
And she was adopted!
Emma, she's so nice!
Sit. (gasps)
Good girl!
(funky music)
So I'm here in the photo shoot,
and I just found Fig.
He is 7 1/2, and he's a toy poodle.
Oh, say hi!
(funky music)
- All right, well there you
go! There's this beautiful set!
- Thanks for joining us.
- Hope you had a good time.
- Getting a look behind the magic.
"Stranger Things" three is now streaming.
(funky music)